ici on est au lycée autogéré de Paris
c'est un endroit particulier bah tout
simplement parce que c'est un lycée
autogéré donc les élèves vont tout faire
ensemble il y a pas vraiment
d'administration il y a pas de personnel
de ménage il y a pas de personnes qui
nous font à manger on a rien de tout ça
et c'est les élèves et les professeurs
ensemble qui vont tout faire
alors ici c'est la cafétéria du coup
dans ce lycée on n'a pas de cantine on a
des repas qui sont préparés par les
élèves et les professeurs le mardi et le
jeudi
[Musique]
est-ce que vous trouvez ça plus cool
qu'une cantine
et puis même ça coûte moins cher enfin
ça dépend des gens mais c'est 3 € pour
entrer plat dessert et c'est bon donc
et du coup tout est fait ici donc au
moins on sait d'où vient la nourriture
et puis ils apprennent à faire à manger
c'est bien ça pour en faire à manger
plus tard ça nous permet en fait de nous
prendre la décision de comment on le
gère voilà si quelque chose me plaît pas
on peut en discuter avec les gens qui le
gèrent pour essayer de le modifier pour
que ça plaise plus à un certain nombre
de gens tout ça bah ici par exemple dans
l'administration
l'administration du coup c'est géré que
presque que par les élèves mais il y a
aussi une personne qui travaille ici en
permanence parce que bah quand il y a
tout le monde qui est en cours on peut
pas forcément gérer les appels les
inscriptions au bac on peut pas y a
notre trop de choses à faire en fait des
fois donc on a quand même une personne
qui travaille ici
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui refusent leur
orientation scolaire qui sont orientées
en bac pro ou en techno et qui ne
souhaitent pas du tout qui veulent
absolument du général il y a ceux qui
souhaitent rencontrer des méthodes
alternatives il y a ceux qui ont une
angoisse terrible de l'école
traditionnelle il y a ceux qui
souhaitent avoir simplement un autre
rapport au monde adulte voilà il y a
ceux qui sont là quand même par
engagement politique et à ceux qui ont
envie juste à un moment d'essayer autre
chose on a cours en BD on est d'accord
bonjour
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous allez prendre vos
manuels qu'est-ce que c'est le paradoxe
du passager clandestin vous pouvez aussi
le trouver sous le terme free rider
le programme c'est le même que dans un
même programme mais pas forcément les
mêmes méthodes les individus peuvent
être amenés à ne pas se mobiliser
alors j'ai distribué des photocopies
alors il y a pas du tout de sanction
lors de retard ou d'absence justement
c'est l'un de notre principe de base au
lycée autogéré de Paris qui est la libre
fréquentation donc l'élève peut
fréquenter les enseignements qu'ils
souhaitent c'est une volonté de
permettre à l'élève de se
responsabiliser de ne plus subir sa
scolarité mais au contraire d'être
maître et à l'initiative des
enseignements qu'il choisit je vous
montre la petite vidéo
qui en fait reprend ce que tu viens de
dire Sky donc c'est sur les différents
statuts des entrepreneurs
comme les élèves ne sont pas obligés de
venir en cours
il y a cette question de comment rendre
le cours attractif fun et en même temps
de faire passer les mots clés les
définitions les concepts donc j'ai mis
en place des tas de d'activités très
ludiques avec mes terminales par exemple
on fait beaucoup de jeux là hier on
était on était dans une salle d'escape
game
je vais le faire promis je te le jure
je t'aime fort comment tu as paniqué
avant j'ai fait une année dans mon lycée
de secteur lycée général ça c'est plutôt
mal passé que ce soit en cours à
l'extérieur ça me plaisait pas en fait
tout simplement donc on m'a dit que
j'allais redoubler et je me suis dit je
veux pas retaper la même année en fait
parce que je sais que ça se passe mal ça
va encore se passer mal donc j'ai
cherché un autre établissement et on m'a
parlé celui-là
j'ai envie d'aller en cours j'ai envie
de m'impliquer dans le lycée j'ai envie
de venir je m'entends avec mes
professeurs et puis quand j'ai refait ma
seconde en fait je l'ai réussi tout
simplement alors que avant je l'avais
raté
merci
[Musique]
ici on a la salle d'Aget c'est là qu'on
fait des assemblées générales on se
rassemble pour les informations
importantes voilà ça peut être quand il
y a une soirée ça peut être quand il
s'est passé quelque chose au lycée
d'emportant n'importe quoi les décisions
c'est plus vues en petits groupes en GB
ça c'est les groupes de base on se
réunit une fois par semaine et pour
prendre les décisions parce qu'en fait
les prendre en grand groupe ça serait
beaucoup trop compliqué
11h à 13h le jeudi on a des heures de
commission et comme on est un lycée
autogéré et ben c'est à ce moment là
qu'on gère tout le lycée il y en a qui
vont faire de l'administration d'autres
qui vont gérer le budget il y a la
commission entretien aussi par exemple
qui s'occupe les réparations ici on est
à la cape la commission d'aide et de
prévention à l'élève il y a quelques
jours il y a l'infirmière et une
professeur qui sont allés une formation
sur tout ce qui est sexisme agression
sexuelle tout ça donc ils ont ramené des
flyers on est en train de les trier voir
ce qui est intéressant pour nous ce qui
l'est pas et là on a plein de dossiers
qui de base sont pour les chefs
d'établissement tout ça et du coup nous
on les récupère vu que c'est nous qui
nous en chargeons et on est aussi en
lien avec des professeurs et
l'infirmière pour
pour gérer tout ça comme on élève on
sait comment on aimerait que ce soit
géré donc je pense qu'on est peut-être
les mieux placés pour faire de la
prévention à d'autres élèves enfin on va
pas la faire nous-mêmes mais pour
l'organiser
[Musique]
alors ça à la base c'est une salle de
cours mais elle est utilisée par la
réunion générale de gestion tous les
délégués se réunissent ici pour mettre
en commun et en fait refaire passer des
informations refaire passer les
discussions des votes des fois je pense
qu'on va passer la majeure partie sur
voilà quand on veut inviter quelqu'un
pour faire voir le lycée ou pour x ou y
raison est-ce qu'on passe par quelqu'un
qui est employé au lycée pas demander à
un prof c'est prévenir c'est pas pareil
est-ce que ça je leur ai excédé en
compte rendu la voix d'un élève et la
voix d'un prof elle est égale et chaque
en fait la voix d'une personne compte si
je mange un coup non mais si je mange un
couscous avant d'aller en randonnée je
vais mourir
le jeudi après-midi en fait on a aucun
cours on a ce qu'on appelle ici des
projets par exemple le projet théâtre
monte une pièce moi mon projet il
s'appelle marshutopique en fait on va
faire de la randonnée pour aller dans
des lieux alternatifs on a prévu d'aller
dans des ecopheurs on est allé dans des
lieux luttes des lieux autogérés aussi
et il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres
projets comme le projet photo il y a le
projet jeux vidéo aussi qui crée un jeu
vidéo donc c'est très très varié
le plus important c'est que c'est un
lieu de vie un lieu dans lequel en fait
les élèves et les profs ont décidé de
partager un quotidien voilà et à partir
de ce moment là autour de ce quotidien
on fait des activités et divers et
variées des cours des voilà plein de
choses la vie c'est pas juste une
histoire de discipline la vie c'est
effectivement c'est avoir des copains
faire à manger faire des courses pouvoir
discuter et puis qu'après en fait ils
sachent faire tout ça voilà et que c'est
ensemble qu'on fait les choses dans une
société donc à un moment l'école elle
doit amener à savoir faire ensemble les
choses
merci infiniment
[Musique]